for you too much you have the safety
exit and I will ignore I'm used to it so
you go yeah we don't have a lot of time
I mean first of all thank you for for
inviting me this is a I have to say a
bad day because we have a big project
due for China and and I have to go and
work on it this morning but maybe at
lunch we can I can try to come back and
we can talk informally if you're
interested anyway I'm going to talk
about the question of infrastructure and
and of course through some of the the
projects that we've been involved with
principally in the in the Earth
Institute I don't know have you had the
introduction yet to know all you did
yeah ok steve is sort of involved with a
different set of issues and I'll explain
what we're doing in a minute but anyway
in general I mean we're in a new phase
as you know of global urbanization and
so I think we're also in a new phase of
trying to understand this phenomenon
which is is of course quite different
than then historical precedents so the
question of infrastructures is
fundamental and in our understanding of
infrastructure of courses has changed he
is changing a great deal so we will look
at a number of concerns
basically the the lab is connected with
a postgraduate program in the
architecture school and with another
post graduate school a program in the
School of Engineering and Applied
Sciences so first of all from an
academic point of view it's it's really
a new he represents a new series of
connections in the University and and I
would say in general that universities
are having to respond rather quickly too
of course changing demands in terms of
what we're asked to do and of course how
how especially for the urban field how
things are evolving in general so what
we're doing represents an interesting
case here at Columbia in terms of how to
to respond to the new realities we will
look basically at a number of precedence
in terms of some of the work we've been
doing this is applied research it's
messy research were kind of think tank
but we're also as they say a do tank
we're very involved with problem solving
of all kinds of different problems were
not specialize in the sense that the
Natural Sciences are specialized we come
up out of course the Earth Institute
which originated with the Natural
Sciences but what we're about is
something quite different and I think
without saying too much about it of
course as designers were very much
involved with synthesis of managing all
kinds of information not as specialists
in terms of the information itself but
as specialists in terms of the
management and of course the problem
solving aspect of what we what we do so
we're basically going to look at region
urban scale and then four questions
which are
is important to any city anywhere in the
world that is waste water energy and
health and and the infrastructure needs
but for all of these of course are
evolving quickly all right the origins
yeah you can probably quite read this
but I'll just explain it you don't have
to memorize but the the earth institute
starts in what 94 I think so it's about
16 17 years ago by very interesting vice
provost in the university micro who's
now president of variable pairs on the
state he moved on to Arizona State's
doing some interesting work there but
this was a very early response I think
in this country to the need for academic
reorganization in the sciences and of
course this is a continuing topic and of
course is growing in a kind of frenzied
way around large programs government
programs like NSF and then of course
through through all kinds of private
initiatives in this case he basically
reorganizes let's say the information
base within the Natural Sciences around
a new academic entity which is the Earth
Institute following the reasoning that
the old academic departments in the
university which really date from the
19th century in most cases are no longer
adequate of course to to the new demands
in
therefore you need a kind of new
hybridization of of that structure so
the earth is too comes into being and
it's basically organized around these
departments which are water energy
urbanization has its in risk global
health poverty food ecology ecosystems
climate and society in education and
this of course proceeds in a very
interesting way to quite a large entity
within Columbia there's I think around
eight hundred people now in the in the
whole of the Earth Institute is a
separate campus which is up the Hudson
River so of course he he combines and
recombined some existing activities and
and initiates new ones is a large
commitment in Africa which is very much
the the kind of domain of Jeff Sachs is
the director of the Earth Institute
Steve who I guess you've heard from his
is the kind of executive director and he
spent more involved with integrating now
Social Sciences where we come in is
about six years ago because
interestingly the Natural Sciences have
urban eyes enormously and by that I mean
that there's a course blurring
distinction between the old category of
Natural Sciences kind of pure
naturalistic concern to of course it's
melding with urban questions and
especially urban infrastructure so now
for example be very difficult to find an
NSF grant around let's say
infrastructure issues without a demand
for an urban connection and usually some
kind of more political community
oriented connection yes what did the SF
going to grab the National Science
Foundation's big institution in united
state grant hojae
is about the October and NSF is is
really the lifeblood of a lot of science
over the decades of course and and
funding stream of NSF and of course
others but let's just say NSF is
extremely important to the sciences so
and the NSF is the main government
entity changes direction people have to
listen whether they like to or not so at
any rate we are then that the lab is an
organized as a response to the
urbanization of the Natural Sciences and
and and of course we then get involved
with let's say more the application side
of a lot of the expertise which is
inside the Earth Institute so I will I
will go through some of these
involvement we can keep it pretty
informal if you have questions some
things more interesting and others it's
it's fine with me but here here are some
of the projects and then you see from
the design side the synthesis of a
number of these concerns with within any
given project you know need to you know
it doesn't matter what these things say
the basic principle is that we we are in
fact synthetic we're very much involved
with design thinking more than then
primary research yeah
so starting at the largest scale it
whoops and some of the questions that
have come about this is an early
involvement with really a 200 kilometer
corridor from New York City we're down
here to Albany up the Hudson River and
the question of the planning of this
corridor which is becoming more and more
important for a number of reasons having
to do from climate change to let's say
densification overdevelopment of course
there's been a lot of work done on
cleaning the river itself but that seems
to reach the ceiling in terms of
effectiveness so there's a whole
question of what's what's next and this
is very complicated because they're
there is in fact no single database for
this corridor so that's the fundamental
first problem which gives to the
question of in fact the need for the
evolution of tools to do what we do and
amazingly you have an urbanized corridor
for 300 years with no real mechanism for
its study comprehensively so of course
in this case we were looking at the
options for developing those tools
you've probably got 40 or 50 different
governments here different databases
some better than others really that the
most indicative
indicator of for example water quality
related to urbanization has to do with
where the storm water outlets are on the
river so so you get a connection between
of course water quality and urbanization
which is a very new connection relative
to let's say urban planning this I won't
go into much detail in this there there
a couple places elsewhere there's a
Rhine Valley study which is very
interesting in Europe there's some work
in California but anyway the basic tool
is going to develop as we're speaking is
being developed has to do with remote
sensing which the Earth Institute has a
big capacity for but the connection
between remote sensing and direct GIS
mapping and your keys remote sensing
satellite sensing so of course in the
military you can now use satellites to
read people's license plates etc as we
know why I'm very careful about my life
but the question is for planning
purposes how do you move from that kind
of very raw data into manipulable
modeling and that right now is a hand I
process so of course that the next
generation of planning software will be
able to do that automatically so you get
from the satellite image to some kind of
planning model without the handwork but
I mean to put it very simply there's an
interesting group in berkeley that's now
gotten pretty far along with us so i
suspect in five years we will be able to
deal with this problem which of course
we can't deal with it
the moment here probably anywhere so
that's one kind of very large scale
involvement worse than some other things
oops just resistive one yeah yeah we
work of course with the the postgraduate
students and in this case just to show
the kind of breadth of issues this was a
study for the city of Vienna it was
quite interesting because Vienna has a
very large planning capacity of course I
was probably 250 people working in their
municipal planning department so one
would wonder and everything is planned
perfectly in the historic Center for
sure he can't touch anything without
somebody's you know involvement but the
question for them that that it turns out
we could have quite a bit to say about
was actually the periphery of the city
in in the question of the dissolution of
east europe west europe and the
connection of vienna to bratislava with
the removal of course the the old border
after the fall of the Berlin Wall so
they are experiencing an enormous amount
of sprawl and basically the connection
of the two cities without very much
experience and in spite of their very
large planning capacity very little
experience with how to how to control
that or even conceptualize it so that's
another I think general question I mean
these are all questions that face cities
everywhere in the world and turned out
to be of course quite quite an
interesting work
another very different kind of work has
to do with using the science capacity in
the earth institute around earthquake
hazards seismology capacity which is
very large relative to planning in the
Dominican Republic Chris Hades over here
they've had their earthquake the next
big one is predicted for this fault here
this is santi anto Domingo here
Santiago's here in Puerto Plata is here
this is a very serious problem you have
more than a million people in this in
this urban region I mean we tend to
think of you know the Caribbean has
little islands with not too much
happening urbanistic Lee which is
completely false i mean the region for
santo domingo's well it's more than two
and a half million this is actually a
million and a half in the region this is
the food this is the breadbasket of the
island and this is predicted to be a
level eight on the Richter scale
earthquake with of course not at all
adequate planning for you know pre and
post event so we this is I guess I think
my hair is wet not to build or is it
quality building
they're already built there there I mean
basically this is almost not discussable
except with the president but basically
this is the city which will disappear
because of the soil conditions and and
it happened before it happened several
seconds ago the old city is still under
so accepting that reality the question
is how what do you stabilize first which
of course is municipal buildings
hospitals is sort of thing how how do
you train a population to you know to
move very quickly they the island has a
very big capacity to deal with
hurricanes but then you have the weather
channel and you know everything you have
warnings in this case you have nothing
so yes Anita has to do with that and it
has to do with reconstruction of course
the city should not be here to begin
with but house you tell cities where
they shouldn't shouldn't be I mean these
are huge cultural questions yeah to
practicality so what you do is you both
go by modeling or to the government
president to understand better what's
going on yes this little he provides a
trainee and serve
this is in a very preliminary stage so
we're finished we're completing report
now on what to do and the president has
seen that and some other high officials
and it will be a noun you know being
public probably within the next month
their problem is organizational they do
have an internal government capacity but
they don't have they very difficult for
them to connect the dots for complex
reasons so I think that the in our case
that the first place to start is in how
to do the planning organization there's
been some UN work as well sponsored by
Spanish government which is basically
arrived the same conclusion different
way but our work is messy so you know I
mean we've met with a president number
of times fact we were just there last
week and he he said well he he would
like a very smart guy by the way who was
born there moved to Washington Heights
here we're just up Broadway there's
500,000 Dominican population it's the
largest concentration outside of the
island in the world he was raised as a
kid here on the streets went to public
school went to law school came back
president and now
he has one more year in office and then
he started his own foundation sort of
like Clinton Foundation
right how did work how did the
relationship with the president oh yes
this even ask yes colonial asked how he
decided on this I don't know actually
kind of a mystery but anyway so we go
back with this study we say okay so
we'll we'll work on Santiago further
imagining that this is the biggest
priority and he said no so he want us to
work in puerto plata here well between
us i think this is very difficult to
imagine huerta plata is this is another
interesting case we that's where we're
down there last week but in this case
it's a three hundred four hundred
thousand people town very old this is
where Columbus first touches land in in
the Americas they promised settled the
settlement there
it's in decline in terms of economy so I
think politically maybe this is a more
it's a clear object but but this is how
we this is our situation we're not we're
not pure science you know where we have
to to move with the no no that's the
cabinet santo domingo is in pretty good
shape they only get hurricanes that's
something i will be destroyed so
reluctant survivors that's that has been
discussed yes there is of course there
is a fault line out here with tsunami
issues too but this is certainly that
really the you know the big the biggest
thing so anyway so this I mean is just
another example where we're continuing
we you know it's a political process as
much as anything else we're very
fortunate to have the President to work
with but of course you you don't have
the freedoms that you would have in a
normal academic work you know so what
that makes it interesting moving to the
new york region here's New York City
here
and of course this is about 120
kilometers 130 kilometers out straight
line under 20 this is in New York City
water system which first of all starts
here the 19th century expands up here we
move from the Hudson Valley to the
Delaware New York steals its water from
Philadelphia which is that I'm here on a
different River system and what we're
finding now is of course that the two
systems are very much integrated in in
the water supply of the city number one
but also number two regionally in the
regional ecology so in this case we were
studying what we call X urban
development that is the the sprawl of
the city beyond the normal commuting
range which is stopped because of the
economy but as of a few years ago was
really way out in this area with direct
impacts on the water supply we'll come
back to this water question later but of
course as who was it Fortune magazine
said about 10 years ago water is the oil
of the 21st century and certainly in the
New York City case is becoming more and
more contentious in spite of the fact
that we have plenty of water with plenty
of water but what we have is plenty of
untreated surface water which is a huge
luxury but that surface water comes with
real demands in terms of maintaining its
quality so that so the water you drink
when you if you I don't know if you have
bottled water here whatever you have but
when you turn the faucet on in New York
an hour and a half or two hours before
that water would be up here somewhere
with trout swimming
being that I like trout fishing I always
think of my trout when I'm turning on
the water and unfortunately in New York
with this luxury of so much surface
water has of course abused its water
source so you know New Yorkers blow
their nose puts it the tissue in the
toilet and flushing so the toilets are
like a wastebasket the very different
mentality then of course in places which
historically have have had to watch
under water supply but we'll come back
to that another oh so we'll stop with me
yes the big contention with that water
supply is now the the discovery of huge
gas natural gas fields in marcellus
shale and of course the the hazardous
extraction of the gas through the
process called hydro fracking which
grants by the way his of course outlawed
here it's very contentious and of course
for the new york city water supply the
huge issue we're also looking of course
maintaining and come back to this
admitted maintaining agriculture in this
area which was traditionally a large
piece of the food system of the city
that nationalizing globalized and now
there's a big movement back looking at
the city we've been very involved with
rethinking the zoning tools of the city
this is 125th street which is just up
here we have big shifts now and
demographics of whites moving back to
harlem
Harlem lights blacks moving out further
south isn't a reversal that has to do
with the new economic realities
nationally and internationally the
question in this case was how to
maintain Harlem as a center of
african-american culture in this process
of course of increased densification so
we worked really as a long political
struggle with a Department of City
Planning initially in kind of an
adversary world in terms of read the
rezoning of the street with the built in
economic incentives for the cultural
further cultural development so that's
another high comment my ethical go ahead
to falling have any back on Europe and
yeah well Harlem Harlem is it as a an
African Americans I mean it's really the
african-american center of in the US
culturally so of course it's a it's a
big economic engine in New York in terms
of cultural activity and commercial
activity and we take you should take a
walking on the corner tsking you'll see
how quickly is changing so three or four
maybe five decades of that activity is
suddenly threatened by the new shift of
basically middle-income white families
coming back which is another long story
but it's that demographic is certainly
happening I mean the young couples with
a kid who live outside the city they
have two cars what taxes are going up
they have a house it's not efficient are
starting to think about of course the
change in their lifestyle in their
lifetimes
to be happening so Manhattan is looking
very attractive it's also relatively
cheap believe it or not relative to the
middle-class suburban lifestyle outside
of the city so we have this this shift
between city and suburbs that's that's
very much underway then slowed a bit by
that the bubble bursting but even that
hasn't really stopped it so it so so
that means of course that the African
Americans support african-americans in
an auto poor actually in Harlem are if
not being displaced finding incentives
to leave and so the city risk to lose
that economy which has a huge global
identity so that I hope that in a
nutshell that that's the problem there's
another corridor which is further up
Manhattan's very difficult here because
hard to cross so 145th street is another
corridor there we've been working on
building in green incentives into the
new zoning these zonings have to do with
increasing the densities of the
corridors across the island and yet
another kind of Manhattan involvement
has to do with a new science innovation
hub and this has to do with the city's
effort to to really reinvent an economy
moving out of the the last half century
of a basically service industry economy
that is finance real estate and
insurance which drove Wall Street for
the last half century or more into
something else and that's a huge
question facing the city as well in this
case this has to do with an initiative
by Columbia
to jump start a new activity moving to
Ghana and a craw we're also very much
involved with economic planning around
slum upgrading in this case with an
entity within the Earth Institute that's
very much involved with with Africa this
is a vibrant informal sector from every
point of view from the buildings to the
economy and the question is how do we as
so-called developed Western culture
understand a fundamentally different
system of doing business which dominates
and so and not only doing business but
developing including the physical
development so that's another whole set
of concerns this is the one we're
working to finish literally today in
China for a new town development in a
fourth-tier city that is a city under
half a million people and those are the
cities that are going to dominate of
course the next huge expansion in China
the Shanghai's Beijing's are finished so
the big effort is in the smaller ones
and this is an interesting story in
itself
we're going there next week for final
review of the work but in this case it's
it's local dominated innovation not
national and the national government has
somewhat liberalized urban planning
policies now such that the local
government is starting to talk radically
about a new infrastructural approach and
I won't go into detail but it's very
much involved of course water climate
agriculture I mean all of these issues
that affect every city everywhere the
same in a crop in the craw thirty five
percent of the food that comes from the
countryside spoils before it arrives at
the city I mean there's a basic
infrastructure issue so so the
interesting thing is that with this
urban worked is really a layer of
discourse that covers you know the whole
picture and cities probably more than
countries are able to talk to each other
about shared questions in spite of huge
differences in terms of location culture
whatever in terms of okay waste in terms
of New York this is the Gowanus Canal in
Brooklyn this work has been going on for
seven years the Gowanus is now
proclaimed as the first large urban
Superfund cleanup site in the US which
is surely deserved enormously polluted
but our our argument here has to do with
the fact that that clean up to be tied
to a new industrial base for the city
and not simply tied to redevelopment of
the canal as a kind
venice in brooklyn condo upper middle
class housing complex so in this case
we're talking about agriculture waste
and water coming together in a new form
of production a lot of discussion of
these ideas here we haven't also the
Gowanus and the the question of seeing
billions of dollars being spent not just
to end up with a clean piece of water
and ground but with basically a new
urban economy at the end of the process
that's very doable except for the
politics of course here again another
side in New York in which this is a
community develop idea for a new eco
industrial park in this case the
facilities for recycling glass into very
high high efficiency fiber optic cable a
new generation fiber optic cable which
has been developed in Japan in terms of
agriculture this is a scheme for very
inexpensive agricultural pods which can
be flexibly placed in in neighborhoods
as yeah right as as kind of hydroponic
yeah we almost did this in Washington DC
but they got cold feet at the end due to
course public space issues but one of
these pods can be built for three
thousand dollars this was very carefully
engineered this is interesting this is a
the application of new artificial tree
technology which has been developed in
the
I'm test center for energy studies
hearing in the Earth Institute and they
there gotten pretty far along with
artificial trees that is machines that
can process co2 back into oxygen more
efficiently than an actual natural tree
so the question what but unfortunately
they're very ugly and of course they
have no sense of what to do with these
things in an actual place where people
would want to look at them so the
question was how then to incorporate
that technology into a public space and
incorporate it with rainwater harvesting
with natural growth this sort of thing
so I'll go very quickly here here's a
prototype for a multi scalar composting
mechanism which is quite simple and
these were to be this you could have a
small one in your kitchen or a large one
as big as this as this this height these
were to be prototyped in the glass box
building which you probably seen out on
Broadway University was very interested
in this and then they got cold feet
again there's always the cold feet
problem this is a study for again around
water and infrastructure and green
building for a new town in Korea Korea
is a very interesting case relative to
China because they're 20 25 years ahead
in terms of housing production and
lifestyle quality of life issues and
they've reached a ceiling of course the
Chinese are very afraid of reaching even
sooner the question what's next in terms
of production especially of housing so
that's and
here's the gas drilling thing with the
conflict between energy and water now
for the first time in New York City
history we always had water energy and
infrastructure working well now we don't
with the gas drilling this is what one
of those gas fields would look like out
here and then finally just a couple more
slides we tend at least not as as
designers to think of health as
infrastructure but it very much is I
mean no CD exists without a food system
and in the case of our work on food
systems which has been pretty extensive
now the last four years we started with
looking at the childhood obesity
question in the US which is enormous and
of course a huge threat to let's say the
health system in general because of the
cost of carrying a kid who might be
eight or nine years old who has diabetes
through to 65 or 70 I mean these are
huge questions so we were asked by
United Health which is one of the
largest health providers the country to
look at this so why should we look at
this one you ask the doctors and they
say well we already asked the doctors
and they don't seem to have any good
answers so we might as well ask you guys
and of course so we move from the
obesity question itself which the
medical profession tends to blame the
victims saying well they shouldn't eat
so much or they should exercise war so
we move from that mentality to the food
system itself which is highly
problematic in this country
it is elsewhere and and we move them to
the food system of New York and the the
food chat of the city this was the
traditional food chat of the city until
the turn of the 20th century then of
course we have the railroad we have
refrigeration refrigerated railroad cars
we start to nationalize to California
New Jersey which is just that way still
has the Garden State on its license
plates of course now his only a fraction
of what it once was in terms of New York
City food system and we're finding that
well for example I forget the exact
figure but 88 a normative piece of
processed food in your new york city
supermarket will have traveled 1400
miles so that's not obviously from the
affirmative maybe it's 12 is 12 or for
it's somewhere in that range I mean
comes from China so or fish from
Thailand you know you name it no this is
not just California of course so that's
obviously not sustainable from a carbon
footprint point of view but also from
the the economy of the city point of
view we need this enterprise now so
there's a huge reconsideration that's
evolving you know as we speak of this
whole question this of course East
Harlem where the child obesity is in
high 30 30 s %
and East Harlem was bent which is just
that way has been the object a lot of
our study we also work in on the farming
side you basically the new generation of
farmers were not working as a you know
the old generation did were very
efficient very knowledgeable so this is
a piece of the equation there's a
blurring of course of urban and rural
now that's happening so it's not just
people moving out to a suburban house
it's enterprise that's rearranging
itself and finally think this is last
slide how'd I do oh sorry we're okay
okay so visualization that's what we do
we make things accessible this may not
be very clear to you but this is a food
desert map of the east side of manhattan
the mountains have lots of food the
valleys have very little food when we
experimented with this I thought
nobody's ever going to understand it
this was actually the one image that
community people understood totally out
of all our studies everybody
so to party okay upper east side this is
East Harlem down here we need to write
out here I would get no claw me faculty
would see this as a food desert actually
this happen it's hard to there's not
many choices here Columbia but by food
desert we mean of course places where
fresh food is not available at all they
tend to be poor neighborhoods so again
in the Manhattan case East Harlem would
be probably the most severe and then you
get the correlation with health of
course so all right so sorry that took a
little longer but